welcome back to las vegas now tonight or
today it might be december 4th
but christmas will be here before you
know it which is why
we are checking in with lifestyle expert
sema cohen who's sharing some great
holiday gift ideas for everyone on your
list
hello las vegas now it's great to be
back and present my holiday gift ideas
for the whole family the holidays are
coming up and
all of us are shopping for everyone on
our list
here are some of my topics here we have
the
perfect gift idea this holiday season
for all the kids in our lives
and for the busy parents who need a
great source of entertainment for their
holidays
we have silly poopies hide and seek
this is the first children's toy from
what
do you mean silly poopy is a plastic
rainbow
hide and seek toy who sings talks and
lights up
when you find it to play all you have to
do is just hide silly poopy
look for it and find it to hear the
special song
that makes you want to dance this is the
perfect
kids gift idea you can find them on
amazon
target and walmart all right
any health nuts out there i got you
covered
health aims to create clean and
effective nutrition
and personal care products that are
artificially
free organic and made in the u.s
the daily vitamin is the most complete
lineup
of 29 fruits and vegetables in a
multivitamin
it's also non-gmo vegan and has
no synthetic fillers i love that the
pre-workout
natural energy supplement fantastic to
take before you work out
or if you know that you have a busy day
ahead it's made with
real strawberry lemonade no artificial
flavors
or ingredients last but not least
skincare they also carry skincare line
this is perfect because it helps you
make your skin looks useful
beautiful and the best part no harsh
chemicals
and it even has vitamins and nutrients
in it
you can find them on health brands dot
co
all right food is i got you covered
sadaf is the perfect gift idea for all
the foodies and cooks on our list
sadaf is a family-owned company that's
been around for over
30 years they take pride in producing
chef inspired kitchen and pantry items
that are wholesome and as close to
homemade as possible
they carry unique kitchen and pantry
items that you absolutely can't find
anywhere else the best part they ship
nationwide
here is a gift idea that i absolutely
love it's full of mediterranean olives
spices gems and their famous avocado oil
if you go on the website you can
actually create your own unique
customized baskets great great idea for
foodies and chefs
all right last but not least black and
berry makes
toxic free sustainable products of the
highest
quality with beneficial ingredients they
strive to have
zero negative impact by using the most
pure organic ingredients
and aluminum to house them black and
berry
living products are 100 organic
non-toxic and recyclable this is
perfect for everyone on your list who
cares about the environment
inside and outside of the home happy
holidays everyone
thank you fema with all